chaque jour la totomanie touche plus
d'individus nous ne pouvions TER plus
longtemps Estel phénomène de société to
tioun to tut en verre en plastique en
métal qu'aorte la couleur et la matière
pourvu qu'on a de quoi touiller ma
couleur
préférée et puis c'est un peu à la mode
parce que dans notre école il y en a
vraiment plein plein plein moi je m'en
s les enfants sont accr le phénomène
gagne les ados on signale même quelques
isolé d'adultes dans certaines boutiques
c'est la pénurie vous les avez pas on
les a pas non non on les a pas eu on
devait les avoir aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
ça s'chète au marché
noir s'achète au marché noir on attend
de fait la rue du Temple à Paris est la
plaque tournante de la tétine chaque
boutique est à elle seule un véritable
gisement de tot prête à imonderer le
marché chaque 10 minutes nous vendons
des des tétines tout le monde en veut
les boulangers les bar tabac les
magasins de cadeaux jusqu'au station
service